when you get a pair of equations what
they can represent is a pair of lines
and often these lines will intersect
they'll meet somewhere and we can find
we've got at least two ways of finding
where is it that the two graphs actually
meet does anyone want to throw out a
suggestion for one of the ways they
remember okay so one of the ways method
one is by using simultaneous equations
and what's lovely about simultaneous
equations is you're not subject to oh no
I didn't quite draw my graphs super
accurately and so my results look very
good
which is something we encountered
yesterday even with grid paper at our
disposal if the numbers are quite hard
to do accurately then your lines don't
end up looking perfect so you can't read
accurate results off them so so
mysterious equations are lovely for that
they're much more accurate but they have
their own problems I'll come back to
them in a second can someone remember
what our alternative method to I
actually just alluded to it it's what we
used esterday you you'll look at the
graph right so I guess the way I would
say it is you would solve them
graphically because it requires a graph
we call it graphically I suppose you
could also call this algebraically okay
now we're going to focus on this second
one in this lesson that we'll use the
first one as necessary here's my reasons
why do you remember these pictures we're
drawing they're just models they're just
models right in fact I'm even going to
write that to help you remember because
they're just models they are approximate
by their very nature so it's a bit silly
to pretend that when you get a precise
exact solution out of your simultaneous
equations you're like oh therefore I can
conclude there's an exact number for
this answer when you have model that may
or may not be true so in some ways it
does make sense to use an approximate
method for an approximate model okay the
other catch is simultaneous equations
once
heisting Lee requires you to know what
the equations are frequently your models
will not like your hat you'll get a
graph you'll collect some data you'll
draw a trendline but you don't know what
the equations ask so therefore you're
like you're dead on arrival you can't do
anything with simultaneous equations if
you don't have equations so here are two
graphs we're going to focus on drawing
them so you'll need a set of axes now
because in this case we do have the
equations I'm gonna teach you a little
trick you know when you draw graphs by
the way I do say trick because you don't
need this trick so if you find it
confusing you're like I like the old way
better that's fine but there are some
things that are very appealing about
this that I will show you in a second
when you draw a graph like this you
can't just have the picture there and
say that's enough detail there are some
important values you need to put to
label onto the graph what important
values might you suggest what kind of
things would I have to put on here so
they'll know this is say y equals 2x
plus 1 and not like 200 X minus 1 okay
yeah I heard the word I think I want to
find out these spots here on the x axis
and the y axis where do I have my
intercepts right so being that you
always need to find out what these
values are I'm gonna show you a teeny
little trick that will get these values
out very quickly okay the trick won't
make much sense the first time I show
you but stay with me and you'll see what
happens so let's try out this first
equation like so the first thing you
want to do is get all of your X's and
Y's on one side of the equation and all
the left-hand side is what we normally
do so I'm gonna get them all over this
side I guess it would look something
like this equals negative 8 you could
have written Y minus 3x if you like that
I'm just writing it in alphabetical
order that's all ok the next thing I'm
gonna do is I want to make the
right-hand side equal to 1 so if I want
this to be equal to 1 I should divide by
something what should i /
negative eight will do a job so if I
divide this by negative a that means I
have to divide the other side by a
negative eight so it's gonna look like
this is that okay so what am I done I've
got all my protein rules on the Left I
want to make this so that the right hand
side is one now have a look at what the
left-hand side is going to be equal to
at the moment it's just one big fraction
this numerator on this denominator I'm
gonna break in two pieces like this and
I'm gonna leave that like so okay so
pronumerals on the left right hand side
equals to one one last step I'm gonna do
I want there to be just an X and just a
Y just a lone X and a lone white on
those numerators so how would I rewrite
this so that there was only an X on the
top hmm the first thing I noticed is I
don't need both those negatives right
like I can get rid of both those
neighbors they cancel okay like so I
know it looks unusual that I'm leaving
that negative eight there but I'll show
you why that's there in a second here if
I just want that to be an X I should
divide through by something what should
i divide it by it have a look just just
this guy I should divide that by three
that'll turn it into an X right so if I
divide the top by three then it stands
to reason I should divide the bottom by
three as well so it's going to become
this now that looks so strange that
looks so weird but actually this is
exactly what I want
see how there's a number matches with
the X and a number that matches with the
why these guys this is the trick part of
it these guys are the intercepts
negative eight is the y-intercept and
eight on three what's a on three 2 into
2 and two-thirds 2 and 2/3 that's the x
intercept let's just quickly draw that
and I'll prove to you that that's the
case x equals 2 and 2/3 so let's put
this guy 1
two three so two and two-thirds might be
about yeah okay well I'm in trouble
why of course negative a I'm gonna have
to draw this higher sorry your graph is
probably fine because you don't have to
hit the bottom of the board but I do so
I'm gonna draw this up here one two
three two and two-thirds I'm suggesting
to you that two and two-thirds is the
x-intercept and negative eight is the
y-intercept how am I going to put that
on here if I go one two three four five
six seven eight that's negative eight
two points is all you need to draw a
graph so grab your ruler out from here
to here draw the line straight through
can you do that for me okay now remember
I said to you well this is a weird trick
okay how would you do this any other way
because you have to find these
intercepts you've been doing it for a
while how do you usually find an
x-intercept what do you do hmm I'm gonna
substitute something in what should I
substitute if I want to find out
y-intercept I should substitute in x
equals zero right I'm just gonna use
another color to do this if x equals
zero then that gives me y equals have a
look here's the equation I'm looking at
right three times zero minus eight
but what's three times zero anything
times zero is just zero so this is
negative eight right which is what I
already found okay how do I find I've
got a y-intercept how do I find an
x-intercept I do it the other way around
so I have to go y equals zero
x equals okay have a look I don't
actually have x equals it's not the
subject I'm gonna have to rearrange a
little bit over here so this is going to
be 0 equals 3x take away 8 so if I add 8
to both sides and lo and behold this is
the same number I drew before okay so
that's 2 and 2/3 I've got the same
result both ways what's nice about this
is that often equations are in a really
easy form to get this into and this gets
your x and y-intercepts
in one hit they're both they're just
sitting there whereas here you have to
do two different steps often I forget
which one's X equal zero which one's y
equal zero so as compared to two longer
steps you've got one big step and it
gets the same result okay whichever you
feel most comfortable with I'm going to
encourage it it's always great to have
more than one way to do a problem
because that way you should do the one
you're most comfortable with you can
check your answer another way and make
sure you got the right answer okay can I
give you a minute to use either method
whichever you prefer to find the
intercepts for this guy because we need
to find where they meet right which
means we need both pictures on the graph
so I'm going to put up my working for
both of those in a minute but I'll let
you have it go first whichever way you
like I wanna have a picture of this on
the same graph so can you take a minute
to do that